good evening everyone thank you for
coming this evening
i'm viviane jennings the president of
rainy day books and we welcome you to
the latest in our 80 books author Series
events our guest this evening is the
author of first strike and a new book
called ron brown's body and so I hope
that you will join me now in a warm
Kansas City welcome anywhere any of the
books welcome for mr. Jack Castle
my family this week thanks for coming
tonight
I'm about to share with you the greatest
untold story of our time and I know the
skeptics and the audience are thinking
for themselves how is it if this is the
greatest untold story of our time that
some unknown clown from Kansas City's
become the literary custodian of it and
there's a couple answers to that
question and one is the Internet I mean
just to speak literally it gives me more
reportorial power in my Westport office
today than the New York Times had
collectively 10 years ago that's one
part of the answer but I also have help
and I just wanted to before I go any
further I just wanted to to thank those
people who helped put this together Don
Covington now stand up Don is a retired
engineer who we started talking about
this early because it's just such a
massive project that goes all over the
world it goes through all kinds of
different technologies the Kansas City
Star called that meticulously researched
and Don has a lot to do with that he was
very helpful yeah right are you hearing
ramen genteel
okay right you know Stan then ray is a
retired
Ray's a retired international captain
for TWA on my last project I got to meet
literally hundreds of TWA people a great
family and at the end of this project
when we got to the plane crash I don't
presume to be an expert in plane crashes
I don't presume to be an expert in
aviation and Ray was enormous ly helpful
I mean and Ray also brought in other
help so we would have our bases covered
and well it's a lot of this is due to
that Dominique is she here my name's
okay I have is hoping she'd come oh
you're here Dominique thank you very
well it's great so came out from which
that I'm gonna talk a little bit more
about Dominique stroll later on don't
make the Angelo is my Croatian
translator so and that proved to be
extremely useful in this project since I
don't speak or understand a single word
of Croatia you know despite my my
language background ah
have any of you ever seen the movie
invasion of the body snatchers the
original version okay the black and
white 50s version right and that's the
best of the versions just for those of
you who haven't seen it just in a
nutshell here's what happens we have
this perfect little town called the
Santa Mira California which is a the
ultimate American town at the time the
50s and in that town then just a normal
sunny day these giant seed buns okay
it's a little far-fetched but it's the
15 remember start infiltrating from
outer space they get into people's
basements and when people fall asleep
these seed pods take over their bodies
they evolve overnight and they become
these perfectly soulless and lifeless
kind of automatons that take over the
bodies of the people they're so like
communist you notice the 50s they had to
understand now at the end of the movie
there's only one unsnapped person in the
whole time town his name's dr. miles
Pannell and it towards the end the movie
we see him running away from me the
townspeople who are after him in hot
pursuit bunnell gets to the highway
outside of town and he doesn't know what
to do cuz they're right behind the mill
runs into the highway and he starts
pounding on the cars that stopped
listening you have to believe me stop
stop stop okay
now the townspeople they reached the
highway and they're about ready to
pursue Bunnell but then one of the
smarter townspeople turns to them says
no no no no let him go no one will ever
believe him okay you'll forgive me if
sometimes I identify with dr. Myles
Bunnell and forgive me to my friends in
the major media if I identify you with
the townspeople your souls have already
been snatched you just don't want the
road
okay like dr. Bernal I have a large
story to tell and it's as I said before
it's it's so large that if I were
skeptic in this audience I wouldn't
believe me if I hadn't met the frontline
truth tellers in this story I wouldn't
believe this story had I not been so
deeply involved and I would not believe
it all in a nutshell it's this when I
started this project and I got an
advance a front I didn't have to come to
any conclusion I told the publisher I
said to all talk of murder in the case
of Ron Brown is irresponsible I was
wrong
what I'm gonna tell you today is that a
dispassionate observer looking at the
evidence of Ron Brown's case will come
to the conclusion that murder is the
single most likely result for the death
of mr. Brown and I'm gonna ask that if
we can reopen the case of Emmett Till
who was one week older than Ron Brown
and whom I talk about in the book
because they were they were paired as
children that a murder 49 years ago in
Mississippi we can certainly reopen the
case of Ron Brown now the last book I
wrote was on TWA flight 800 and those of
you who are skeptical hearing this will
become not just doubly skeptical but
exponentially more skeptical how is it
to some unknown clown from Kansas City's
disgust noting the two greatest untold
stories of our time it's a question I
asked myself on more than one occasion
and here I'm gonna cut to the chase and
what happened to Wi-Fi 10-under and that
is to avoid a disastrous near war of
retaliation against either Iran or Iraq
and we weren't sure which we concealed
what happened to that plane we concealed
the terrorists demise of TWA flight 800
in the months leading up to the 1996
election those are two great stories I
expect your skepticism I'm gonna address
this this talk tonight to the skeptical
among you I'm not gonna try to talk to
the believers I know there's some of you
here I'm gonna talk to the skeptics I'm
not gonna try to convince you that
either of these stories is true in and
of itself but what I'm gonna try to
convince you is the media atmosphere in
the years 1995 nineteen
96 was so essentially corrupted that a
stories of this magnitude could go
unreported and you can miss them now you
may not believe that right now but at
the end of the evening I think you will
and then once all I'm gonna ask you is
do open your minds to that possibility
once we open your minds and we can start
talking about reopening these cases what
we're talking really is not about a
political scandal our our Constitution
was devised around bad politicians I
mean our founding fathers knew that the
corrupt people would want to hold office
that they expect it we're really talking
about media scandal an ethical collapse
that's unprecedented in American media
history and let's see if we can address
some of the more salient charges here
tonight first a little free book and I
don't know if I should do this because
the star game is such a lovely review
one Sunday those are your sort I'm
reluctant to attack them now you think I
should if you insist
this is a true story and it and it will
speak to why I'm here tonight eyes out
for a walk this is oh five six seven
years ago maybe more in my neighborhood
and I had a hat on it said u.s. Park
Police now some of you understand the
joke of that and some of you don't well
I just happened to run into one of my
neighbors who was I was out walking it
was art Brisbane as a publisher the
Kansas City Star and I should say that
that hat was given to me by jean-louis
who was the Resolution Trust Corporation
officer who blew the whistle on on
whitewater now in the 90s if you
remember two years ago Time magazine put
on the cover female whistleblowers as
the people of the year well in the 90s
they were providers
I mean Jean almost literally died on the
witness stand under the pressure that
they brought to bear against her to try
to humiliate her and to drive her into
the ground all she was doing was trying
to tell the truth she wasn't the only
woman who came forward in the 90s this
book could not have been written without
one of them that's not on the hill who
is Browns confidante and business part
who cooperated with me fully in the
writing of this book I should say and we
spent probably 40 hours at least on the
telephone
and I first I met her in in Fort Worth
of the Fort Worth Club and the night I
met her where she still checking me out
I asked her to take her time making a
decision and we're sitting in the lounge
of the Fort Worth Club when a news
bulletin came on and it was they had
found Elizabeth Smart alive and Nalanda
who had had a Christian experience which
has allowed her to come to where she is
allowed her to survive decided that was
a sign perhaps I did too that we should
proceed and so again the other woman in
this book the two heroines of my book is
a very human book is Kathleen Janowski
she's the forensic photographer Navy
forensic photographer 20-year veteran
who discovered the hole in ron brown's
head for what she paid with her career
as i said three of her colleagues three
pathologists also had their careers
ruined whistleblowers were not
appreciated in 9 news there are other
whistleblowers of what got me into the
TWA 800 book was Elizabeth Sanders the
the wife of my partner in our project
Jim Sanders who was arrested and
indicted for conspiracy for daring to
introduce her husband an investigative
reporter to a pilot who was working
inside the investigation that was all
she did she spent a year in hiding and
was arrested and convicted there are
others who were pariahs it as Paula
Jones asked Linda Tripp what the word
pariah means whistleblowing was not
appreciated in that decade no okay I'm
out I have my hat on I just a little
digression I run into Arthur Brisbane
and my had sex u.s. Park Police he says
what's with the hat jack I said well
that's my Vince Foster Memorial huh you
know and I explained to him that Vince
you know that the Park Police came into
the case and they screwed up the case
and he was you know one of those people
who believed that Vince Foster was
murdered are you
I said no I've read a lot about this art
and I said I don't know if it was
murdered but I think that there was
there is some tampering with the body I
think there's something wrong with this
case here's the Brisbane does and for me
it's provided the ultimate lingering
image of the media in the 90s
as soon as I say that
and this is literally true and if you
were here I'd say it too he puts his
hands on his ears and says and he walks
away and says I don't want to hear it I
don't want to hear it I don't want to
hear it okay I'm the executive editor
cities business magazine and he's the
publisher to start listen to me stop you
have to listen like dr. Myles bonel
again you know well quickly a lot of you
have heard there's a famous Roper poll
that came out it I think 1993 about the
92 election in which they asked
Washington correspondents who they voted
for 89% of them voted for Bill Clinton
4% of them voted for George HW Bush and
3% voted for us Perot
there's a natural sympathy for Bill
Clinton in those first two years however
that sympathy did not reach this stage
about sequences for another two and I'll
tell you why but they that sympathy was
enough to allow Bill Clinton to create
an image that was absolutely essential
for his election and reelection and that
is in that culminated in his anointment
by Toni Morrison in 1998 as the first
black American president I'm gonna read
what Morrison said about him Clinton
displays almost every trope of blackness
single-parent household foreign poor
working-class saxophone playing
McDonald's and junk food loving boy from
Arkansas now I don't fault Morrison for
coming to this conclusion because this
is the image that the media were
providing uncorrect it for years
Duane Wickham wrote a very valuable book
called Brooklyn and black America in
which he describes he asks prominent
African Americans to tell him about why
Bill Clinton is so popular among blacks
and America and he was right and I'm
just gonna read you some of their quotes
I'm not gonna bother the names here he
had a poor upbringing said one he came
from the other side of the tracks said
another in some circles he was probably
called poor white trash
set a third what set separates him from
every other president and basically from
most white politicians is that he grew
up with a lot of black kids said another
every one of those statements is false
if you've read Bill Clinton's background
he did not grow up in a single-parent
household he had a stepfather who
adopted
who took him into his life at age three
and loved him dearly and the Clinton
family was appalled when they when Bill
used his stepfathers alcoholism to
present himself as something other than
what he was his stepfather came from an
affluent hotsprings family
Bill Clinton grew up going to all-white
segregated schools the best secret
segregated schools and hot springs and
all the counts of his childhood there
are no black contacts at all not only
that but he grew up semi affluent his
mother was a nurse anesthetist and David
Maraniss in his book first in his class
talks about how the Bill Clinton
household became a shrine to Bill
Clinton as a teenager that is the
refrigerator was stocked with everything
that he wanted that he had his own
bedroom I grew up in the 60s I assure
you I don't have my own bedroom and I
don't think there was two kids in
Arkansas who had their own bathroom
which Poe Clinton had and he also had a
Buick convertible sitting in his
driveway which he drove to the
whites-only Country Club that was his
upbringing and then he went off to
college and he was described by Moranis
as the soul of moderation he stayed out
of all racial issues he came back to
Arkansas the first race he got involved
in was trying to get Orval Faubus 'as
you know the school door blockers
successor elected to Congress that was
his background but it's not the fault of
these people that they perceive this
because the media were feeding them
these images for for all of this time
uncorrect this is important because he
would depend on this base forever for
the rest of his campaign and when Ron
Brown threatened that base Ron Brown
made himself not nearly exploitable but
expendable now this brings us to Lani
Guinier who plays an interesting role
and the shoe is nominated by Clinton to
be the head of the Civil Rights Division
early in 1993 to cultivate his images
friends of black America Clinton went to
a dinner party at Lani Guinier house a
week after who was elected with Hillary
there were a law school friends she was
thrilled as anyone would be and then
shortly afterwards he came back and
offered her they had the civil rights
posts in the judge in the Justice
Department she proved very controversial
and her nomination process got bogged
down with a lot of stuff whose
understandable
I want to digress one second I just want
to show the skeptics certain things you
don't know about what happened in
America during this period during Lonnie
Quinn years a confirmation process which
was kind of involved an incident took
place now you heard about the church
burnings scandal where black churches
were being burned across the south
correct we've all heard of that and only
one of those churches was anyone Killed
and it was the Mount Carmel community in
which 28 black people died in the fire
this happened in 1993 how many of you
know what I'm talking about
okay something be done we're talking
about wake up 28 black people killed at
Waco how many black people in America
know that there was a single black
person in that church compound none
Lonnie Gwen here didn't know what your
shocking cuz she was being nominated for
this civil rights
post more than a half of the dead at
Waco or racial minorities 42 out of 80
this isn't something I read I counted
heads I went down head by head by head
the FBI had given him video cameras so
that they knew but they only showed on
the media white people they wanted you
to think that these were you know
peckerwood Christian gun-toting Texans
who weren't worth preserving 28 then
check that out you didn't know that
happy the skeptics and the sodium sent
to know that in any case Bill Clinton
dumped Lani Guinier under pressure
Lonnie Quinn year went on to write the
most damning book of the Clinton
administration you want to find out what
the administration was like read Lonnie
when you're his book Hillary Clinton in
the middle of this process passes are in
the hall
Lonnie when Eric tries to appeal to her
and and Hillary walks by and says hi
kiddo and just keeps on walking that's
the last word that Lani Guinier ever
heard from Bill Clinton or Hillary
Clinton in my hip my some sort of in
figuring of living history was in her
book living history there is no mention
of Lani Guinier
in Hillary Clinton's book her name does
not appear
answered this incident Bill Clinton's
approval rating in black America dropped
from 87 percent to 53 percent and this
was panic time in a Clinton White House
for Ron Brown had happened at both the
worst of times and the best of times
Ron Brown was involved in one of the
most egregious scandals ever to hit a
commerce and it hit a cabinet membrane
in recent time Ron Brown was an
imperfect human being he had some many
good capabilities we'll talk about these
but in his years at Patton Boggs and in
the Washington DC money machine
political gin mill he got caught up and
when he had to go from making
three-quarters of a million a year to
$150,000 a year he had a cache Jones
that he couldn't satisfy he had
developed a lifestyle that was beyond
his control so what he did and this is
beyond dispute is that he solicited and
accepted a $700,000 bribe from the
Stalinist North Vietnamese government
now when he first dealt with him he met
with him three times the first meeting
at that time he was not yet nominated so
he was doing acting as a lobbyist so
there's nothing necessarily wrong about
that at the second meeting he had
already been nominated so now it becomes
very suspicious by the third meeting he
had already been confirmed that third
meeting took place in the Commerce
Department office and his witnesses to
it when when the story started to leak
out what happened is that there are two
Vietnamese involved the media would just
report to them as to Vietnamese and
write them both off but in fact one was
an American citizen the other one was a
communist agent the American citizen
when he thought what was happening that
his his offer of a you know finding a
lobbyist to open up trade with them
Vietnam was turning into a bribe he said
I don't want any part of this he went to
the FBI and he went to the media
the FBI listened to him and took him
seriously the media blew him off they
just dismissed him and they would write
funny stories about him from there on in
when his stories started leaking out Ron
Brown denied it he denied it publicly
said I had never met these guys I've
never heard of these guys
know anything about it but through the
persistence of the American the
vietnamese-american the Miami Herald
broke the story said yes they did me
three times the third time was in a
commerce department we can prove it and
then bran said oh yeah okay I forgot
right he had already opened up a bank
account in Indonesia to receive the
money however he never took the money
because he got a tip from the Justice
Department that the FBI was
investigating this was all going on why
lining when year was being her process
was happening at the end of the day
Clinton couldn't dump Ron Brown because
he would have killed him in black
America Ron Brown was most popular black
politician in America at the time
what's scandalous about this is the way
the media treated it this story is so
black and white it's scarcely even worth
you know documenting here's what the New
York Times said about Lee Thanh Binh the
Vietnamese American a courageous
whistleblower who went out there and put
his neck on the line and tell this story
for seven months this small-time
businessman has been spinning a wild
tale of international intrigue the New
York Times wrote that after his tale of
three meetings had been confirmed by
Browns lawyer now what happened is they
fixed the grand jury in Miami and they
had to get him out of this case they had
to get Brown out they couldn't let him
go down there was no investigation by
the media at all into it they just blew
it all off and then when Ron Brown does
emerge vindicated the grand jury never
even called him the headline in New York
Times Ron Brown re-emerges of Hall in
halls of power and thrives as that the
investigation into his accepting these
bribes that was a quote detour New York
Times Ron Brown however knew that he had
been had he knew that he had screwed up
he knew now that he fully depended on
the Clinton White House that's from that
point on he was to be their boy their
bagman or as he told Nalanda Hill
Hillary Clinton's and that thing travel
guy he did not like what happened to him
they were perverting his missions from
that moment on to some degree deserved
it's a large degree deserved it but
new they have me knew he couldn't defy
them from their everything after he also
got another shock that year
that's when Robert Woodward's book the
agenda came out if you've ever read that
book what he talks about is how the
Clintons first year in office they
created a domestic policy a battle
between the deficit hawks and them and
the Liberals and in that book Ron Brown
realized here he was Secretary of
Commerce
he gets one mention and slighting
mention Robert Woodward in the front of
that book identifies Ron a Bill
Clinton's domestic team there are 31
names on it now remember a lot of
african-americans bought into this
administration because it was so
inclusive because he put blacks in
positions of power like they never had
before
31 names on the domestic team having
them think were black or Hispanic zero
therefore women one of those was Hillary
in the book I counted there are seventy
photos of identifiable people zip blacks
zip Hispanics and this is the domestic
team the foreign policy team didn't even
have the illusion of inclusion this was
and things were just about now to get
worse now they were gonna get bad and
that was the election in 1994 November
this is a this is one everything really
went to hell in the American media if
you recall the Democrats was in a time
of peace and prosperity was 52 seats in
the house eight seats in the Senate they
lost control of both and Newt Gingrich
emerged like grinning like a Cheshire
cat sitting over their shoulders and
they were horrified not just in
Washington but all across America I know
something about progressive circles and
so my wife's a university professor and
she's here tonight actually a Dean now
which is good so he's been a Dean that
she's Dean Dean interim but that's
probably the best guy and so I was at a
Christmas party right after that just to
give you some sense of the panic that
said it cuz some of you had seen this
actually now they don't have Christmas
parties anymore must been a a winter
solstice party I was at
and I'm not exaggerating I stumbled onto
three conversations in which Newt
Gingrich was being compared to who okö
say Hitler Hitler and finally in the
third conversation I couldn't resist it
any more I said let's go through a
comparison okay Hitler is a socialist
and Gingrich ways and free enterprise
Hitler is the statist Gingrich believes
in limited constitutional government
Hitler was the original anti-smoking
Nazi Lou King which was a friend of Big
Tobacco Hitler was a vegetarian Newt
Gingrich was a cardboard Hitler was a
pagan the King which was a Christian
Hitler hated Jews Gingrich was a friend
of Israel Hitler liked boys Gingrich
liked girls
I said I know the Republican Party's a
big tank but it can't possibly be this
big any him that was happening all
across America now Ashcroft is Hitler I
did
I got 18,000 hits on it when they did an
article a couple months ago Ashcroft
Hitler okay this led to led me to
believe that we're about to witness a
perfect storm of misinformation because
I know this attitude was prevalent also
in Washington New York and they were
frightened media were frightened they
weren't frightened Bob Dole never would
be but they were fighting the given Newt
Gingrich Republican president and the
combination was intriguing so for the
next two years the media Bill Clinton
and Hillary Clinton decided that they
would do whatever they had to do to
could get reelected and the media
decided that they would do whatever they
had to do to not notice what Bill
Clinton who were deciding to do and
there was a lot not to notice starting
with the election itself Dick Morris is
savvy guy he comes the Hillary calls him
right after the election not bill
Hillary and says help us what do we have
to do maura system okay if you can
rustle up about eighty-five million
dollars we can go on TV starting in July
95 and start running ads and
we'll leave them defenseless and they
said well want the media protest and
here's what Maura says no we just don't
run the ads in Washington in New York
that's all we have to do here's the Mars
quote if those cities remain Dorothy
says the national press would not make
an issue out of our our ads of this we
felt sure they weighed 85 million
dollars worth of ads they just didn't do
him in Washington in New York totally
illegal
I mean circumvent that every rule that
there was here's how the Thompson
committee describes the campaign was
about to follow and Fred Thompson is
relatively restrained in fact he
overlooked something I'll get to in a
second this is the Thompson committee
report formal report the president and
his aides the mean the office of the
president vice-president took advantage
of minority groups pulled down all the
barriers that would normally be in place
to keep out illegal contributions
pressured policy makers and lets
themselves open to strong suspicion that
they were selling not only access to
high-ranking officials but policy as
well millions of dollars were raised in
illegal illegal contributions much of it
from foreign sources but who's worse
than that and Ron brand-new it because
he knew what the Cox committee would
find out two years later and that this
money was being raised and a quid pro
quo and that as we were selling our
high-tech security especially the
People's Republic of China for this
money and Ron Brown was right in the
middle of it he was the bagman he hated
that he hated that they were perverting
what he's thought at the beginning were
were real missions to stimulate trade
across the world now Robert would only
two books were written about that
election both of them were written
simultaneous with the election
contemporaneous one was written by
Robert Woodward is called the choice and
he bailed that in July because he
realized I think the dole Clinton race
was among the dullest races he could
ever choose at least on the surface and
he afterward however in the paperback
edition he realizes he missed the story
and he talks about the eighty-five
million dollars worth of ads and he says
he admits he goes no one in the media
really caught on and then he says he and
he has the grace to admit this he said
Eve Astley underestimated the
significance of money in the campaign he
notes too that the ads themselves is the
quote were deceptive enough to be a
there was no coverage of this in the
media he admits this there was only one
other book written about this campaign
and that's why I went back to write this
book because I want to write about the
96 campaign I only stumbled into a
murder mystery now was written by Evan
Thomas is a muckety-muck with newsweek
and in the four words of the book here's
how Joel Klein describes the 96 election
you just heard the Thompson committee
hears that Joel Klein describes it bill
Klein Bill Clinton by shrewdness luck
and love of the game came back from a
near-death experience to win a second
term that's out Newsweek describes the
campaign this is Britain after the
Chinese fundraising scandal broke Evan
Thomas describes it as a quote little
flap that marred a nearly perfect
campaign okay that's the kind of
reporting that was going on in 1995 1996
there was a biography written of Ron
Brown two years after the Thompson
committee came out it was by a New York
Times reporter by the name of Stephen
Holmes in his book he makes no mention
of the Thompson committee at all he
makes no mention of judicial watch's
activities at all what he says he
summarizes all these scandals into one
sentence and we're talking here about
the selling of seats on these missions
that Brown was forced to do by the White
House one hundred thousand dollars a pop
after November 94 that morphs from
expectations who the price of the
mission here's what Stephen Holmes of
the New York Times says after the
Thomson Committee after the Cox
committee with lack of solid proof of
the charge that is selling seats it was
constantly mocked by Brown's allies
that's it he's written a hagiography of
a guy who was likely murdered for what
he knew okay Brown felt otherwise he
knew he was in this thick of it and he
hated it in the last six months was life
I can't say why my sources here are so
good is that Nalanda hill his confidant
was targeted by the same independent
council that Ron Brown was and as
condition for her not rolling over on
Ron Brown she
insisted that he share with her every
bit of trouble that he was in and she
saw it all
I double-checked everything I could
double-check in the longest told me and
always checks out
she's testified to everything I'm gonna
tell you under oath in several different
courts and no one doubts her work now
Brown was sort of now we had a new
Independent Counsel on his back for this
deal with Nalanda he was living with
that and then they did something that
pushed him over the top they targeted
his son Michael as I mentioned earlier
Ron Brown was imperfect in many ways but
he loved his children dearly it was also
the very good job in the US Army as a
captain every place where they asked
something of him he performed but he
kept running into places where all he
had to do was show up and coding the
Clinton White House then when they
invited his when they targeted his son
Ron Brown slept at that point he said he
started going to church for the first
time in his life even his family noticed
this he started collecting religious
medals and praying and it was it was
clear that there was something wrong in
the man's life
he and Nalanda role played as to how he
should approach the president he finally
found the opportunity had to be
one-on-one in the family quarters and
the only two people were at that meeting
where Bill Clinton and Ron Brown the
only two people who probably know what
happened personally or Hillary Clinton
along the hill because when Brown left
that meeting came back immediately in
debrief nonde who was staying at the
White Water Hotel as a matter of fact in
Washington and the first thing Brown
said to her which is a detail that rings
true to me he said he was insulted
because Clinton met him in stocking feet
and Bram is a meticulous dress and he
took that as the insult it was in any
case when brown asked Bill Clinton to
take off the Independent Counsel you
know to squeeze that the star of it to
somehow get rid of it to get Michael out
of it somehow
Clinton kind of blew him off and then
Brown played his trump card he goes
listen and this is in February of 96
before months before anyone ever heard
of John Wang and James reality or mocks
our reality or all those johnny chung or
all those other people before anyone
knew about China and Asia he said hey
I'm prepared to talk about
I'm running money at Asia I'm running
technology into into Asia because you
don't want it you don't want me to talk
and he says besides because I've lost
control of Nalanda he realized that made
mistakes soon as you said that no one to
realize they made a mistake to spend the
next three years of her life in hiding
I'm just gonna summarize quickly what we
know for sure about Ron Brown's case
then we'll take some questions
weeks before his death as I mentioned he
starts going to church this is even his
family notice the Croatian now he flies
he's going on a mission to the Balkans
the Croatian government insists on the
Dubrovnik stop 36 hours before the crash
this is unprecedented for a security
mission six months after the Dayton
Accords in a war-torn Ian area the air
force calls the nearly two-mile
deviational of course at the last minute
inexplicable that was their word and by
the way when I sent away for their Air
Force report which really turned this
investigation around in many ways I was
first we were content to work with a
hundred page summary because I knew that
they would I figured I would drag their
feet through Freedom of Information Act
we had this happen when they played it
under etc and the charges multiple
thousands of dollars and when I balked
at the price which was in the thousands
they said they emailed me back they said
we think you should have this it'll be
there in a week we're waiving all fees
and I emailed them back I said what is
the nicest thing my government ever done
for me and as Ray will attest we spent
the next few weeks you know we're like
the first settler first people in it the
Sutter's Creek you know they're just
nuggets all across the stream and you
just have to know what to look for and
ever there for the and rate has a
special report by the way and I'll say
this if you want to see the special
technical report that Ray genteel
prepared email me at Jay castle at
aol.com miss JC a shi li tol calm and
put on special Ron Brown report and on
this thing and well I'll email you that
the technical report it's it's too much
detail too to go into in the book but
it's it's very persuasive
ray and his colleague came to the
conclusion that the and that
ground-based navigational systems had
been sanitized at the airport the
ground-based navigation system was
sabotage
causing the plane to crash make a
perfect landing right into a mountain
now what gives that credence is the fact
that the Croatian who was responsible
for those ground-based navigation
systems nico jakku ik shows up with a
bullet hole in his chest three days
later and he is at not at work the day
this crash occurs the son of Franz och -
German the neo-fascist strongman who was
running Croatia at the time Miroslav was
head of intelligence and he ruled that
the 46 year old jakku ik was despondent
over failed romance and shot himself in
the chest now when the people at the
armed force Institute of Pathology heard
that and they have a kind of a Gallo
sense of humor there at the big mortuary
in Dover processing the 35 bodies they
thought was kind of funny you know cuz
hey people always shoot themselves in
chess they tell jokes
Kathleen generosity was the chief of
forensic photography on the day that the
bodies this was Easter Sunday four days
after the crash Ron bran is I mean
Kathleen is providentially decides to
calibrate her light meter by shooting
the x-rays of Ron Brown they were posted
on the light stand and then she starts
her task and that is of shooting the
body and aware of what happened with
Vince was so she went to be extra
careful so she starts at the head
looking very carefully through her
camera shooting down and she looks down
and says my god she says it's out loud
looks like a bullet hole in Brown's head
now all the other pathologist came over
and they all agree that it looks like a
bullet hole but here's what did not
happen
there was no friends of testing there is
no search for an x-ray there was no one
in no informing the Brown family and
there was no autopsy by order of the
White House that brown body went right
to embalming right the state never came
out a little while later Janowski by the
way who's just a great truth teller and
the sweet person you know a really
likable person when you meet these
people you see the real human beings and
not just you know people you read about
a short time after that she confronted
the head pathologist said hey what about
this bullet hole a Naval Intelligence
staffer overheard her and whispered to
her hey you know we destroyed the head
x-rays and Janoskians earlier against
all regulations and John says why did
you do
and the intelligence person said because
they showed a LED snowstorm and Janowski
had to inquire what's the light
snowstorm and the the intelligent person
yeah that's when I get bullet fragments
in the brain you know it's the light
snow storm so they destroyed the x-rays
imagine a ski shop she goes back then
she remembers that she took photos of
bronze x-rays she goes back to her files
and finds a 35 millimeter slide a
Brown's head x-ray and sure enough there
is the what looks like a light snow son
she calls the one guy she trust this guy
Lieutenant Colonel Steve Cogswell and
she says take a look at this and cogsa
looks at it and said oh my god
this is incredible Cogswell had flipped
out when he first heard about the lack
of an autopsy the man would there be an
autopsy and they turned him down now
mischievous guy that he was he starts
showing the Ron Brown autopsy and his
program that he teaches the FBI mistakes
and autopsies you know so he puts the
brown thing up there Christopher ruddy
the Pittsburgh tribune-review finds his
way to Cogswell and the story breaks the
story breaks this is just one of those
great ironies in the conservative press
in December 1997 and then like some sort
of rogue salmon it jumps from the
conservative stream into the
african-american stream and now White
has those problems on its hands Dick
Gregory
in fact I talked to a few days ago is
totally behind this book in reopening
the case is goes to the Armed Forces
Institute of Pathology on Christmas Day
and surrounds it with police tape and
calls it a crime scene right bless his
heart
and now Clinton's the White House is
getting anxious
Kwasi maloom he comes on board in early
January 1998 jesse jackson comes on
board now the White House is getting
anxious and defensive they the arm my
secretary Army comes back and says now
he died of multiple blunt force injuries
just like everyone else well in the 22
volume Air Force report I found his
death certificate he alone of the 35
people there dies of one force injuries
to the head he alone it is 35 people as
long as a hole in his head so on July On
January 17th 1998
this becomes the the media storm really
hits the african-american community the
Washington after all America runs a
full-page front-page story now there's
three pathologists and Kathleen Janowski
who've gone public the same thing from
the armed force Institute of pathologist
and saying we need we demand the
investigation you remember what else
happens on January 17th 1990 a bill
clinton gives it that position on paula
jones and for the first time the word
Monica Lewinsky answers the record two
days later
Drudge goes public BAM just the Ron
Brown story gets washed off the pages
now it's I've had people say the Bill
Clinton plan that no we didn't plan that
he just got lucky and that's where that
stands today if that weren't enough by
the way I could have ended the book on
what I found that in the airforce report
is that the reason the ostensible reason
that Ron Brown went to Croatia in the
first place was to broker a sweetheart
deal between the neo-fascists to Franjo
Tudjman and the Enron Corporation
Tudjman is desperately afraid of going
to the Hague and be tried as a war crime
or criminal Casilla Milosevic started
the whole mess six months later a week
after the November election he finds
himself at Walter Reed Army Hospital
having his cancer treatment there's a
convenient time for him mr. to German
the one other thing is someone this is
where Dominique comes into the story
I'm in deep in the Air Force report I
find this Peter Galbraith who's the
American ambassador talking about a
woman named said thank aghast
so danke is the liaison between the
Enron Corporation and the Croatian
government she's supposed to be on ron
brown's plane and at the last minute she
decides not to fly with ron brown she
goes with the Enron executives who took
their own plane very providentially and
so Peter Galbraith mentions this the Air
Force investigator and the Air Force
investigator says that's the woman we're
looking for that's the woman we have to
talk to well I go through the whole
report there's 180 interviews and as I
thank aghast as an among them
so I pick up the phone and I found her
in five minutes and she didn't want to
talk to me of course but that's you know
not unexpected then I went into the
internet and started looking for zedenka
gasps I'll had the Internet
and I pull up a picture and the Croatian
have put one of People magazine and
here's to thank a gash a big books and
read had a nice looking lady
one arm around Alexis Herman who is who
brown felt betrayed her at the end and
was the White House sort of trip planner
for places like Croatia the other arm
around now guess you know Hillary so I
immediately call up Tom because I
Dominic what am I looking at here what
am I reading I have no idea what this is
you know and she translates it for me
basically it's a wedding reception at
the White House hosted by Bill and
Hillary Clinton for Alexis Herman and
her new husband there are fewer than 40
people in attendance Al and Tipper
Podesta Panetta senators governors and
to thank aghast as a charmed life that
this lady is living one last story and
I'll take some questions here I've had a
lot of people ask me about this moment
and that is the the moment where Braun
Brown's funeral some of you have seen
this on the Internet it's a classic
moment in American media Bill Clinton is
walking away from a funeral service with
actually a fellow named Reverend Tony
Campolo and they're talking in there
laughing as they walk along and Clinton
is laughing then he catches the camera
to the side of his eye he drops his head
comes up I think it's here now the media
of course only chose to run that last
part now a less favorite president would
have had that transitional moment
wrapped around his neck like an
albatross some some mischievous
cameraman obviously snuck out the real
version now before I could write about
that in the book I wanted to make sure
there was true that was really at the
Ron Brown funeral because the weather
was not with the Ron Brown to know
whether it was like so I called kampol
and to his credit he talked to me and he
saw it's not what do you think though
Jack yes it was at the Ron Brown
memorial service a day before the
funeral but it's not what to think he
goes we were recounting how yeah you
know black celebrate funerals and and we
were telling stories about
african-american funerals we went to
above the bomb where just look joking
and laughing and then he said I switched
the subject to partial-birth abortion
and when I did that
Bill Clinton changed his tune I said I
said well I said I by that Toni but
you're still laughing and joking you
know and he said well okay that must've
been later that or if someone you know I
said you know presidents have a
responsibility to the cameras okay well
so then I decided to check out to see
whether there really was a partial birth
abortion bill on the desk of Bill
Clinton at that time and sure enough
there was had been sitting there for
three weeks and then in perhaps the
single most cynical moment of the
Clinton presidency Bill Clinton goes
back in the immediate wake of the Ron
ban funeral and signs vetoes the
partial-birth abortion bill when he
vetoes that he says I'm only vetoing
this because this bill will you know be
don't worry I'll protect the life and
health of American women I've checked
the numbers in Kansas all abortions of
partial birth abortions in Kansas over
the last several years have been done to
protect the emotional health of women
there are no instances of parts of artha
borscht ins being used to protect either
the physical health or the life of a
woman and I've seen this bumper sticker
says when Bill Clinton lies no one dies
well I beg to differ
ok just I'll take one more quick moment
the great Mormon no I gotta take some
questions here first let me tell you
about the invasion of Body Snatchers
they had two endings that they filmed
the first ending has dr. Myles Bernal
running out onto the highway yelling
stops and no one does in movie ends
right there this thing Hollywood they
tested it and of course audiences didn't
like that ending so what they went back
and they went back and shot a new
beginning and a new ending and a new
beginning we see it doesn't start in
Santa Mira it starts in a hospital psych
ward and dr. Myles Vanel has been
brought in and that they're looking at
him skeptically while he tells this
story about you know about these aliens
see father are you okay
sure okay doctor you started started and
then they have at the end of the movie
now he's not on the highway but he's
back he's finished telling his story now
he's back in this psych ward and they're
they're getting a straightjacket ready
about ready to take him away when
another emergency comes by and the
doctor says no what happened it has a
strangest thing this giant chunk of seed
pods fell over and broke this man's leg
and then I said see pods and the music
comes in you know and then call the
police call the alarming you know and so
the audience is left with a hopeful
sense you know I like the second ending
better I like that sense of how I'm an
optimist I like that simpler tend to
poke an optimist and and I think America
today like America and the invasion of
the body snatchers will be saved and
it'll be saved the same way by people
like yourself keeping your open minds
asking for these cases to be open
spreading the truth and keeping the
faith thank you
what my mom did a good job getting you
guys out here tonight just quickly just
some announcements before exact
questions but if I take questions if you
come down to this mic it'll be better
for questions
when Richard Clark was here last week as
a proof of his non-partisanship he came
here to do a to stump for Jamie Metz was
running for Congress on the Democratic
side so to prove my non-partisanship I
want to give endorsement to Steve Dennis
who's sitting here he's running for
Congress on the Republican side
white southerners running for state
Senate swipe is here right where are you
boy this year they're good
again I'm just proving my
non-partisanship in the Richard Clark
strategy by endorsing candidates and
also there will be a reception
afterwards it is a cash bar and all
don't you know expect a lot but it's a
reverse which is two blocks from here
it's at the corner of Jefferson and Ward
Parkway in the Red Room okay so after
the Red Room and a probably under my
name
I don't have any questions or comments
longings from mother once you come up to
the mic if you were to degree no one
wants me first seven once we set it
right is this you know it's working yeah
two questions one you mentioned that the
thing that sent Ron Brown over the top
was when they targeted his son yes but
you didn't say what his son was doing or
why the son was targeted I'd like to
know that and the second question is
what is your theory at on the timing
when Ron Brown was killed I mean was he
killed on the plane obviously if he was
everyone else died too right that
doesn't make a lot of sense that's a
good question first one first and this
is a it's a very complex case I and
something I don't go into when I do
radio even because it's so complex is
the Oklahoma case the case that killed
Michael I mean they brought Ron and
Michael down came out of Oklahoma it had
to do with siphoning money out of an
energy company and Michael was sent
there to be the essential to conduit to
Ron Brown for Ron Brown setting up his
company is very involved but there are
both guilty as Nalanda says in a
wonderful Texas 'yes they Michael was
guilty as a goose and they had him he
was looking in prison
the second question really goes through
the heart of the book and in the book
what I do at the end is a I just lay out
all the evidence and I let the reader
make up his or her own line and the
evidence is I would say is very strongly
suggesting Ron Brown was Merck I mean
the the most plausible scenarios whose
murder it's not conclusive that's why
this case has to be reopened I haven't
seen his done all those autopsy I don't
know even if I could do an autopsy I you
know I'm a doctor technically I'm not a
the appendix going kind and but there's
only one scenario there's only one non
accident scenario that makes sense of
both the plane crash
and it's this that plane was purposely
misdirected into that mountain then
there was another misdirection that
occurred there's a four-hour diversion
the NATO rescue search and rescue people
were sent out over the Adriatic this was
probably purposeful the plane is a mile
and after the airport it's like if a
plane you know the plane the airport
we're on 47th Street and the plane
crashed in Brookside it would take you
four hours to find them I'm messy
equipment just to get put that in
perspective and it was found
accidentally by villagers now the only
scenario that makes sense is this the
people who were commissioned to kill Ron
Brown were not commissioned to bring
that plane then they're commissioned to
kill Ron Brown I believe they they went
to the scene with that idea in mind
found Ron Brandt who was further from
the plane apparently than anyone else
and had no other obvious lethal injuries
and that doesn't mean he wasn't dead at
the time but they may not have known
that I think it was the coup de Grasse I
think I went there just to make sure
they had done their job they knew who
was investigating it anyhow son and
worried about yes sir
I'm you know a little bit of background
you know Clinton was the first president
to fire every US attorney right at the
start second he was the only president
right to fire the FBI director I don't
know if he's the only one he certainly
did right and after he filed after he
fired
William sessions you know what having
twenty-four hours later
yes foster body was found at Fort Marcy
Park right I mean Ron Brown are just one
of many mysterious deaths best foster I
mean have you done miss resource for
events fun oh yeah I'm just going to
stick to what I know and the years 85 96
yeah the second-highest ranking
government official since JFK to die
under mysterious circumstances
yeah now we've got a lot of other dead
bodies I mean there's no accusation I'm
just saying call it coincidence or what
but we've all seen these lists but the
word is Internet
what when for those who don't know the
word is Arkansas right and there is well
over a hundred people that have died
under mysterious circumstances around
William Jefferson Clinton there's a
dangerous presence and you know the
other thing is most of these people the
vast majority have been Democrats well
I'm in fact they know what happened in
the East wonder feel like I'll let you
come no right now that's a good point
because in the whistleblowers I was
talking about Kathleen Janowski Liberal
Democrat she was a volunteer at the
White House and in the book we have a
picture of her and uh hi Hillary Clinton
I know on the hill Liberal Democrat look
I didn't matter
you know I mean Jennifer flowers is a
Democrat I suppose and they have to
resort to any other questions comments
and yeah you can stand up I'll repeat
your question
yes Nalanda no Underhill is now she
lives in the Dallas area
she said she stopped being afraid on
January 20th 2001 and I asked her I said
who'd you vote for you know what she
said
felons aren't allowed to vote I forgot
she was incarcerated she was the only
one to keep her quiet that she was tried
and convicted on tax charges and totally
bogus she's a woman of great faith
though and her faith and she'll tell you
the first to tell you saved her for
three years she was in hiding an
experience would have broken anyone else
and she had no one there is no interest
group no support group even her son
abandoned her at the time because he
they thought you know that she was as
bad as they were saying she was so I
rely mean you could write a faith-based
story about her endurance here Jake
the whole yes repeat the question right
all right the the hole in the top of Ron
Brown said is about point four or five
inches in perfectly circular hole those
of you seen the photos you know what
makes the difference is those who've
seen the photos know that this hole was
into an existing laceration
so the scalp is kind of pulled back
there anyhow so it's perfectly round
hole the testing of it was so cursory
and so superficial that it's really hard
even for the pathologist the dissenting
pathologist while three of them by the
way had their careers ruined
especially Cogswell who was sent to
examined dental mowers he was their
number one gunshot specialist that they
don't say anything more than we
absolutely need an autopsy I mean you're
not gonna say it's a bullet hole they're
not gonna say these are bullet fragments
they just saying we need an autopsy
we need to reopen this investigation yes
sir
that's right he said the the wound was
right right at the top of his head so if
it were uh a bullet it could have easily
gotten lost in the body without you know
any kind of search for an exit wound or
anything like that those are friends of
Casper to my right yes ma'am the
families of the other victims I tried to
contact the I dedicated this book by the
way to the six US Air Force personnel
who were killed
through no fault of their own the two
pilots were pillar eight after that
because they had to find someone to
blame sixteen other Air Force personnel
had their careers ruined including
ironically the highest-ranking black
officer and military Brigadier General
Stevens
what they got him on they had to find
something so they said they should never
let him fly into that Airport well they
were commanded to fly hands at an
airport essentially they don't I have
not heard from the other families yet I
was gonna go look for them but I thought
I'd rather let them come naturally
rather than trying to exploit them or
whatever yes sir
Jack the question I have is maybe off
off-center but I like your reaction the
Enron plane and the obvious conclusion
in listening the Enron plane carrying
guys from Texas I'm paying two dollars
and 60 cents a gallon or two dollars and
20 cents a gallon today this energy
question the Enron deal the Enron deal
is a interesting piece did you go in
your research did you attempt to find
out why the guys with Enron were on
their own plane and the lady who was the
go-between chose not to take the flight
did you do any research into that
specific question that you can comment -
well that's a good question I tried
without any success when I got this a
think against her secretary said don't
be surprised if she doesn't get back to
you immediately well she never got back
to me again I I had that happen a lot
now what I will say is this is I do not
believe at all the Enron had anything to
do with ron brown's death I'm sure you
probably do as a black and as a person
deeply concerned about the issue of the
partisan nature of imagery I believe
with no data that the Enron Corporation
in Texas the in Ron corporation that
with no data not being on that plane
with Ron Brown and the very evidence
that you have already presented someone
knew you'd have to nearly conclude that
someone knew that that plane was
ill-fated that's a conclusion I've
reached listening to you I'll read the
book carefully well my comment is I
would I would hope that in your research
and in the effort to raise the project
that you described with Dick Gregory and
font Roy and others I'm looking around
the audience tonight
the Emmett Till question was reopened
because someone in Kansas City who
happened to be black and identified with
the Emmitt Till question and the
injustice that was there pursued that
issue to an end mm-hmm I would hope that
you don't happen read the book excellent
presentation tonight don't be too
certain about who was not involved
oh no I'm not certain at all it's just I
don't have enough evidence to to
conclude that they did and I say in the
book too is a literal sentence because I
thought a lot about this sentence I said
the prudent reader well can well accuse
the Clintons of nothing worse than
dreading the unknown they did not want
to know what happened to that plane they
did not want to know what happened
Ron Brown I mean I'm not gonna go beyond
my evidence in terms of accusations by
the way I should say to is that tomorrow
night and you might be interested I will
be speaking at the Pentecostal Church of
God in Christ on 800 East Meyer
Boulevard because we're gonna take this
to the community emotionally tied up
into what you've now posed we've used
Jesus Ron Brown I'm I'm I'm fascinated
by your point on ron brown's use of the
bible use of the church be careful okay
thank you sir
yes ma'am i started the project I first
met Nalanda Hill actually had done some
preliminary research but I I met no on
the hill in February of of 2003 and I
essentially stopped writing the book in
around I forget about February 2004
probably I buy it helped and you know
that helped a lot and then and I work
very hard I get up early in the morning
and I I write is people know me can it
says yes ma'am it was a the what was the
size of the airplane is the question
asked it was a modified Boeing 737 so
there were 35 people on board Raymond
how many people would that hold as a
commercial airliner okay just to give
you some size it would normally hold 100
to 140 people yes sir
J right right now they said it was a
military transport he said anyone who's
flown on those would much rather take
the Enron jet and I think you're I think
you're right and that's why I'm not
overly suspicious at the Enron
executives yes sir yes good questions
the question is couldn't have been
altitude triggered bomb and elaborate on
Shelley Kelly which I'll explain in a
second you know when I first got into it
I thought I was gonna find it's just
like TWA flight 800 in other cases but
this was a case of a political of
terrorism covered up for the sake of
political expediency but the evidence
argue strongly against it that flight in
to that mountain was perfectly
controlled all the way right until the
time they got to the mountain perfect
dissent you know everything was under
control so I rolled that out I also rule
out the possibility of shoulder-fired
missiles or anything else based on that
same because we have the AWACS data they
flying platforms and that's basically
how we ever tracked that Shelley Kelly
was the surviving stewardess tech
sergeant for the air force flight
attendant there were a lot of rumors
about her death the rumor that
circulated a lot was it she was alive
when the plane crashed a helicopter came
with American special forces on it she
got on the plane
and then someone slashed her femoral
artery and she was murdered totally
false in every detail except for this
she survived the crash she might have
survived if this search-and-rescue
operation had not been diverted but that
plane was on the ground for five and a
half hours and a search and rescue
people Croatian people did a good job if
the Croatians were the executioner's
we're really just talking about a
handful of intelligence people the
search-and-rescue people did a sincere a
decent job to do the best and when they
got to her it was 8:30 that night it was
five and a half hours after the crash
she was barely alive then she had a
broken back and a broken leg there were
no helicopters of get in because by now
the storm really had picked up and
she died when he they realized they were
gonna have to carry her down the hill in
the pouring rain on a litter and she was
dead by the time she got the bottom the
hill yes sir I apologize but at the
beginning you talk about eight hundred
there's always kind of interested me the
official reason for the flights crash
was explosion if you'll tank right and
at the beginning of the what happened in
the investigation there was some
references to some missiles some people
saw but it said that kind of died and do
I understand you to that you feel that
very strongly if there was some kind of
a terrorist missile that brought the
plane down well I will say this and this
is there was a serious events that
happened in the years 1995-96 I believe
that anything that people have been
accused of doing they might have done
here's what we know that TWA flight 800
for sure okay we know that there were
270 eyewitnesses that watched streaking
zigzagging objects come up off the
surface these are in a Hamptons by the
way and these people used to being taken
seriously I hate to say that but they
are and they watched it culminate in the
explosion of the airplane the FAA picked
up an unknown object merging with flight
ta to the great hundred a second before
it blew out of the sky we also know that
explosive residue was found all over the
plant several photographs were taken of
the incident here's what we're told four
years later that those 270 people
suffered optical illusions that the
radar was a glitch on the computer
software that the explosive residue was
the result of a careless dog training
exercise done in st. Louis five weeks
before the crash and that for the first
time others by the way the photographs
all had scratches or dirt on them and
for the first time in the 75 year
history of commercial aviation a plane
self-destructive in midair because of
fuel tank problem and we believed it you
know how many of the 270 eyewitnesses
New York Times interviewed 0-0
interviewed one total eyewitness the
only interview person answered was one
who did not see the streaking missiles
if you want to know who the architect
of the TWA flight 800 and what they call
it exit strategy is you want to know you
know he boasts about in his new book
Richard Clarke against all enemies read
pages 120 127 Richard if you watch it
and come down and talk to you about this
you know who was the executioner of the
TWA 800 strategy Jaime Garelick Deputy
Attorney General for Bill Clinton at
that time I wrote my first article
asking for her to be removed from that
Commission in April of 2003 a year
before anyone else got to it you read
you follow that case you see why she was
appointed anything could happen in 95 96
all terrorist investigations in that
period were contorted and tailored to
advance the political outcome that was a
hope for in 1996 and I'll stand by that
I just take all the evidence I have and
share it with whoever wants to see it
thank you sir
I just well thankfully one final comment
I read the paper this the other day in
Kansas City Star that the FAA will take
till about 2013 they're gonna study fuel
tank problems and planes before they do
anything about it because order because
of the cost involved I think you said
good question I would take about two
more questions I know they kind of wrap
up yes sir in the back
this is mostly a white audience and I
wonder if you have spoken to black words
in what they what the response you know
I'm going tomorrow night in fact as I
mentioned earlier I'll repeat that not
to the Pentecostal Church of God in
Christ however I will tell you this is
it a few days ago I was invited by Joe
Madison who's probably the leading black
talk show host in Washington DC to talk
on his show he had on with him Dick
Gregory veteran activist and Walter
Fauntroy a former congressman and there
are totally on board
these guys had picked up this banner in
1997 and only to have it swamped by the
Monica Lewinsky's they're totally on
board I don't would you explain they
totally believed and what I've just
presented to you tonight
the theory represented new tonight in
fact they were helpful and they were
dick regularly particularly was useful
in getting the story out so there's Joe
Madison that is why I think this is the
only way this story will ever surface
the conservative media simply don't have
the clout to surface the story but the
african-american media do and that's
what I'm hoping will happen and I think
once that opens a lot of stuff will open
will have a vertical Pandora's box and
stuff okay one more question I know it
was some saying yes ma'am you're back
right and if I'm right it's we're
starting that tomorrow night right
right in the question was asking what
should the audience do to bring this to
the attention of of a black audience and
your husband is black is that right and
and we're gonna do it starting tomorrow
night we're gonna take it to the
community and anyone you know who wants
to hear this message I'd be happy to
come there and talk about it
I have nothing you know all the evidence
I have same thing with TWA flight 800 I
just put it on the table and say if I'm
wrong tell me but this looks awfully
convincing to me and I'm not I can't say
conclusively that Ron Brown was murdered
I wouldn't say that but I will say this
that case certainly deserves to be
reopened I will say that the at the
Armed Forces Institute of Pathology what
we watched was criminal obstruction of
justice what we saw in the Air Force for
the first time in the history of the Air
Force on friendly soil they were not
allowed to do what's called the safety
investigation that's the first phase in
which determined what brought the plane
down they were forced on day one to move
immediately to the accident phase which
is what accident brought this plane down
and that's all they were allowed to
investigate and they didn't like it I
thank you all for coming and I will just